over the years that I've been making
videos I've visited quite a few strange
elevators and lifts and every time I do
I get emails from people in Germany
saying what about the one in the New
Town Hall in Hanover and look I don't
want to become that weird elevator guy
but uh I finally made it this new town
hall is the only one in whole Germany
with a dome that's the first specialty
and another one is of course our curved
elevator that's the only one in the
world the elevator was opened 1913 at
the same time as this building was
finished they didn't want to change the
design of this building otherwise they
had to install this elevator just in
middle of the main
hall so they found one spot on this
building one small Tower and elevator
follows the form of the Kola it starts
in the third floor of this building 42 M
High
8.3 M side weights this elevator
technique was developed during the
construction of this building elevators
were already fairly common in high
buildings by the time this was
constructed but this elevator has a
unique design requirement it means to
travel up the side of a dome the whole
Elevator Shaft is curved it's not a
diagonal straight line like the Eiffel
Tower lifts the track bends as it goes
up about 17° and it doesn't Bend evenly
it's not a smooth curve the path the
elevator takes is irregular and lumpy
that would be a design challenge today
let alone a century ago the new elevator
was built by the company Lots from
Hamburg you cannot use this elevator the
whole year because in the winter there
was very slippery there on the Dome so
each spring there are many Hanover
people who are really cannot wait to see
again Hanover from above the various
parts and mechanisms of the original LIF
were replaced over the years and in 2007
what was left was ripped out a few
months later this brand new elevator was
completed and it only just fits at
points there's only 5 mm of clearance
between the cabin and the wall at other
places there's lots more apparently
during testing and construction it did
bump and scrape the walls sometimes like
I said the path is Lumpy and also the
floor panels of this new lift they can
be transparent obvious question how do
they keep the cabin vertical as it goes
up I assume this would have some kind of
clever self-leveling mechanism like a
finic railway or the tram at Gateway
Arch in St Louis or maybe a floor with
hydraulics in it so it would stay level
as the cabin moved around it but no the
solution is simple they don't keep the
floor level the whole cabin is just
dragged up the side as one I I can't
lean on these doors but I want to I have
to lean on this pole we started out on
the ground at a slight angle passed
through vertical about halfway up and we
ended up leaning a little bit the other
way because a floor with a tilt of a few
degrees
isn't really a big problem for a short
Journey so there you go Germany you can
stop emailing me I have finally taken a
trip on your
elevator for a video about an elevator
ride that was a lot of
steps